[Music]
the world of pop music can be so
confusing
but it's hilarious when song lyrics are
misheard we loved it so much we decided
to create a list of the funniest
misheard song lyrics get ready to rofl
because these are crazy
we are still laughing at number one like
this video click that thumbs up button
and subscribe for our latest videos at
the things now buckle up guys
here are the 30 funniest song lyrics you
misheard Panda imagine dragons blew our
minds with the explosive song thunder
but this catchy tune had some people
belting out a different word during the
chorus the real lyrics are thunder feel
the thunder but some fans thought they
were singing panda Phil the Panda while
pandas are probably nice to feel we
doubt that that's what the band's had in
mind rebel with a kickstand according to
one Twitter fan Portugal the man's feel
it still is a song about a time machine
in a motorcycle this man posted on
Twitter that he thought the lyrics said
oh I'm the rebel with a kickstand I've
been feeling it since 1936 ok there
James Dean we also thought we heard kiss
my little baby girl in the knee-high
marine Wolverine and crying in a bakery
Camila Cabello
has fans dancing and laughing at the
commonly misheard lyrics of her songs in
ain't no crying in the club instead of
let the beat carry fans her the bakery
so don't lose any tears over those
toasted bagels guys also and never be
the same it sounds like she's singing
nicotine hammering Wolverine instead of
nicotine heroin morphine you like
hammering Wolverine better Selena is
gonna beat up Russia in Selena Gomez's
song bad liar we heard some interesting
lyrics in the seventies tastic music
video Selena is walking the halls of her
school obsessed with a teacher who looks
like Selena Gomez wait is that her
anyway there's a part where she says if
you're the art I'll be the brush but we
heard
I'll beat up Russia that's a pretty big
task Selena you might want to stretch
first
Alicia Keyes is the what the
hit song New York by Alicia Keys and
jay-z is a powerful anthem paying
tribute to the big city but wait did we
hear that right - Alicia Keys justing
I've become a wet dream tomato oh right
it's concrete jungle where dreams are
made of our bad that makes more sense
you don't even know what a wet dream
tomato is how deep it's your love
Calvin Harris and disciples are
responsible for a ton of spontaneous
dance parties when you hear their songs
how deep is your love you got no choice
but to drop everything and jump around
it's such a fun love song but we have
one question what is Calvin saying it
sounds like he might have a sweet tooth
because it sounds like she's saying -
tell me how deep is your love candy
cookie Shawn Mendes is tormented by her
chicken we love the song stitches by
Shawn Mendes we always thought he was
singing about a girl but then we
listened closer and heard something
rather odd it sounds like he says we did
until I can't breathe chicken well that
changes the whole meaning of the song it
sounds like he's in love with an abusive
chicken it's hilarious to picture Shawn
in the chicken coop singing to a sassy
hen Adele's rolling in the deep' we've
all been there that low place where a
bad breakup makes you say crazy things
that don't make any sense that's why you
believed Adele when we heard her sing we
could have had it all never had that
beep tears of butter fall you get it
sister you are so heartbroken you're
talking nonsense we got your back and
we're sure you've got awesome feet and
delicious tears be strong girl he'll
find someone new SIA rides the Buffalo
in the songs bang my head by David Greta
featuring SIA and study rap fans found
some pretty funny misheard lyrics in the
song SIA sings bang my head against the
wall though I thought lightheaded now I
know I will not fall I will rise above
it all for what fan turf was I will ride
the Buffalo oops what you hear that way
it's hard to hear anything else
radioactive imagine dragons song
radioactive had one young fans singing
about geology her mom posted the lyrics
her daughter sings every time the song
comes on
radio instead of radioactive for
young-sam sings riding a rock dude
riding a rock dude if you listen to the
song she's not far off he does kind of
sound like riding a rock dude he totally
sounds like something a kid would do way
to go little rock rider Taylor Swift's
coffee shop lovers t-swizzle's playing
space is awesome
but when she sings about her long list
of ex-lovers fans heard something else
they heard all the lonely Starbucks
lovers the fans really ran with this one
there's a ton of pictures on Twitter
poking fun if they miss heart lyric our
favorite was from the superfan Brianne
Farrell who dressed up with her besties
for the Swift's 1989 concert as
Starbucks drinks holding the little
hearts so cute fits perfect
flashlights pitch perfect fans love the
song flashlights
whether it's Hailee Steinfeld or Jessie
J belting out this gorgeous number it
perfectly captures the fears and
insecurities of a young college student
about to spread our wings and fly it's
how you miss hear the lyrics in the song
it sounds like they sing stuck in the
dark but you're my flashlight when the
actual words are stuck in the dark but
you're my flashlight X's and O's Elle
Kings obviously got a pretty low opinion
of her exes she makes that pretty clear
in her song X's and O's but wait did she
just say they hunter like goats oh all
bad she said hot me like ghosts that
makes much more sense for a second there
you're wondering if L had a traumatic
experience with some goats in her past
we've never heard of hunting goats
before 21 pilots we love the song
heavydirtysoul by 21 pilots
the music video is dark and gritty and
there's a drum kit on fire but since
we'd love to find the humor in even the
darkest of places we couldn't help but
chuckle when we misheard this lyric in
the original song who sings can you
my heavydirtysoul but we heard can you
save my heavydirtysoul oMG I his
adorable and hilarious
I love meet Hailee Steinfeld is in this
countdown again because we love her so
much her song love myself is empowering
to young women everywhere but we can
help her laugh when we misheard the
lyrics and thought she said any time
that arrived I love me the song really
says any time that I love I love me but
we support you loving yourself and a
good state Kaylee you deserve to be
happy
locked away the song locked away is a
pretty deep song about a man who is
asking his girl to stay by his side but
some fans put a funny twist on this sad
love song after the part when he says if
I judge her life man would you stay by
my side or is he gonna say goodbye
bastard would you tell me Rhino the real
lyric is can you tell me right now
September song in his hit September song
JP Cooper is singing about a fading
romance but fans misheard the first line
of the song and thought he said our love
was strong as Aladdin but the actual
lyric is our love was strong as a lion
this got us wondering who is stronger
who would win in a fight Aladdin or lion
we may never know but these misheard
lyrics have us rofl man in the mirror
okay we're gonna take it back a few
years to Michael Jackson's introspective
song man in the mirror this song has got
it all passionate vocals high pitch
accents and a powerful message about
making the world a better place it also
has a funny misheard line in the song
michael sings no message could have been
a clearer but we have always heard no
mustache could have been any clever oh
that's not right Waterfalls while we're
kicking it old school we wanted to bring
up TLC's waterfalls this song is also
one with a strong social message about
young people making bad choices we love
Lisa left eye Lopes wrap in the song but
when she says dry the tears from my eyes
no more lonely cries we heard tears from
my eyes no Bologna cries now everytime
we hear the song we can't stop thinking
about Bologna crying love me like you do
love me like you do by ellie goulding
is the perfect love song is
passion excitement and total abandon and
how you hear her say love me like a dude
what we don't even know what that means
what kind of dude alley just any dude
lol we're just kidding
we know it's love me like you do but
it's fun to sing love me like a dude
touch me like a dude drag me down we
love one Direction's drag me down but we
thought it was a little weird when Lewis
sang the shell of a mannequin never peed
his bed what Lewis has got some odd
sleep habits but good for you that you
never pee your bed dude wait our sources
just informed us that the actual lyrics
are the shell of a man who could never
be his best Oh certainly clears things
up Bruno Mars uptown funk kids say the
funniest things when eight-year-old
Sarah was listening to Bruno Mars sing
uptown funk and he got to the part where
he says too hot hot damn little Sarah
heard something completely different
she was bobbing her head and singing -
hot hot pan that's so cute
we can picture Bruno frying up some eggs
on a skillet singing and dancing - that
for sure Goodwyn Sarah my powers turn up
Rachel Platten this fight song is a
great song to play at the gym it's a
girl power anthem that is strong
passionate and about turnips wait what
it totally sounds like she is singing my
powers turnip hey girls just gonna do
two feel strong right we looked it up
and the real line is my powers turned on
yep that sounds a lot better than what
we were singing cheap thrills SIA is
called to have a blast with little cash
is a total fan favorite but some of us
misinterpreted the lyrics and went
dumpster diving after we heard her say
it won't be long till I hit the dumpster
with the dumpster imagine our
embarrassment when we found out the song
actually said hit the dance floor excuse
us while we pull this shredded newspaper
out of our hair set fire to Lorraine
this one was so funny a fan even made a
meme about it Adele's set fire to the
rain takes on a whole new meaning when
you change the lyrics the fans meme Fez
That awkward moment when you
accidentally set fire to the rain after
miss hearing Adele's lyrics poor
Lorraine ever since that song came out
she has really had to watch her back and
care
fire extinguisher with her at all times
farting carrots Selena Gomez has done it
again and looked good for you she
seductively sings about how she is 14
karats
no she's refined and precious like a 14
carat diamond but many fans heard at
Barden carats when asked about this miss
Hart lyric in an interview with BBC
Radio Selena said well wouldn't that
just start the tone really sexy and like
that's what you want to hear a girl say
she joked Anna Kendrick when I'm gone
everyone loves the cup song from pitch
perfect fans have duplicated the cups
dance all of the country we gotta warn
you after you hear this misinterpreted
song Larry you won't be able to go back
to hearing the real words in the song
she sings you're gonna miss me by my
walk you're gonna miss me by my talk oh
but bantered you're gonna miss me by my
taco you tacos royals lorde song Royals
is super catchy and fun to dance to the
mini fans heard let me be your ruler you
can call me green beans instead of let
me be your ruler you can call me queen
bee
all hail queen green bean it's hard to
take the song seriously after that even
a song about gold teeth Grey Goose and
trippin in the bathroom lady green Venus
super edgy you guys as long as you love
me according to fans after they heard
Justin Bieber's song as long as you love
me he may have some odd aquatic
fantasies at least that's what it sounds
like in the lyrics
some fans heard him singing we could be
starfish we could be homeless we could
be broke when he really sang we could be
starving we could be homeless we could
be broke that's pretty out there but
it's also pretty funny
hold the drama Joe Josie Wow has some
awesome songs about standing up to
bullies and having fun while doing it we
heard her song hold the drama we began
to wonder if she sings some part of it
with her rubber duckie in mind if you
listen to the song it it kind of sounds
like she's singing
rub-a-dub tie it up with a bow the
actual line is wrap it up tie it up with
the bow and
that's it for our 30 funniest song
lyrics you misheard thanks for watching
the things see you next time
[Music]